we're told a partially filled tank holds
30 liters of gasoline with an 18
concentration of ethanol
a fuel station is selling gasoline with
a 25 percent concentration of ethanol
what volume in liters of the fuel
station gasoline would we need
to add to the tank to get gasoline with
a 20
20 concentration of ethanol pause this
video and see if you can figure this out
all right now let's work through this
together so let's first of all just
remind ourselves how concentration
relates to total volume to the volume of
the ingredient the way that we calculate
concentration
is that it is equal to the volume of the
ingredient which is in this case it is
ethanol
over
the total volume over
total
volume
now this is already interesting because
this first sentence tells us a lot
it tells us our concentration it tells
us our total volume and so if we know
two parts of this in theory we could
figure out the third part let's try that
out we know we're dealing with an 18
percent concentration that's going to be
equal to they haven't told us our volume
of ingredient we just know that the
ingredient is ethanol
volume of ethanol
over
the total volume they have told us 30
liters so if we multiply both sides by
30 liters
that's going to give us the volume of
ethanol because those two cancel and
what we get is 18 percent of 30 let's
see 18 times 3 is 54. so this is going
to be 5.4
liters
is equal to our volume
of ethanol not only will this hopefully
make a little bit clearer how these
three relate but this is also likely to
be useful information for the rest of
the problem but now let's go to where
we're trying to get to we're trying to
find a volume in liters of the fuel
station gasoline we would need in order
to have this concentration
so let's set v
equal to that
and we're trying to get a 20
concentration so what we could write is
our 20 percent concentration
is going to be equal to our new volume
of ethanol actually let me write that
out so it's going to be new
volume
of ethanol
divided by
our new total volume
our new
total
volume now what's going to be our new
total volume we're starting with 30
liters and then we're adding v liters to
it so our new total volume is going to
be the 30 liters we started with
plus the v liters that we're adding
and what's our new volume of ethanol
what's going to be the ethanol that we
started with the 30 liters times 18
percent which is 5.4 liters
5.4 liters plus the volume of ethanol
we're adding well to figure out the
volume of ethanol we're adding we just
have to amend we just have to multiply
the volume we're adding times the
concentration of that volume so it's
going to be
that's the concentration of the gas that
we're adding times v plus
0.25
v
and now we have an equation to solve for
and the best thing that i can think to
do is let's start by multiplying both
sides of this times 30
plus v i'm also going to multiply this
side times 30
plus v as well
these two characters cancel and we are
going to be left with on the left hand
side
this
over here 20 of that is going to be if i
distribute the 20 percent 20 of 30 is 6
and then it's going to be plus i'll
write it as a decimal 0.2 v i'm just
distributing the 20 over this expression
here and then that is going to be equal
to
on the right hand side i just have the
numerator here because the 30 plus v
cancels with the 30 plus v
i have
5.4
plus 0.25
v
and now let's see
my v coefficient is larger on the right
so what i could do is try to subtract
the 0.2 v from both sides so i isolate
the v's on the right so let me do that
so minus 0.2 v
minus 0.2
v
and then actually i'll just do one step
at a time
so that's going to get me on the left
hand side
is equal to
5.4
plus
if i subtract here this is 0.05
v
now i could subtract 5.4
from both sides
and what i'm going to get with get is 6
is or actually 0.6 i have to be careful
is going to be equal to 0.00
v
and now to solve for v i can just divide
both sides by
0.05
that's going to get me this is the same
thing as 60 divided by 5 it gets me that
v is equal to 12 liters
and
we
are
done and if you want you can verify the
new concentration when i add 12 liters
of this concentration to the 30 liters
of that concentration you can verify
that i now have a 20 percent
concentration of ethanol